مسيره الخلود هو اسم الحمله التي اخترعها
فلسطينيون للمطالبه بتسليم جثامين تحتجزها
اسرائيل حمله تضمنت اقامه اعتصامات في عده
مدن بالضفه الغربيه المحتله اكبرها امام
مخيم الامعري للاجئين الفلسطينيين قرب
مدينه رام الله شاركت فيه والده اسير توفي
الاسبوع الماضي داخل السجن بعد صراع مع
مرض السرطان ورفضت اسرائيل تسطيم جثمانه
انا جاي اطالب بكل الشهداء الموجودين عند
الاحتلال وبحسب نادي الاسير الفلسطيني
تحتجز اسرائيل منذ عام 2015 جثامين
الفلسطينيين الذين يقتلون برصاصها في
مواجهات او في هجمات لاستخدامها في عمليات
تبادل المستقبليه وحين تسمح بدفنها يكون
ذلك وفق شروط صارمه اقدم الجثث بحسب
النادي يعود لانيست دوله الذي توفي عام
1980 كما توجد جثه محتجزه لخمس النساء
للشهيد فلسطيني محتجزه في مقابر الارقام
وفي الثلاجات ويحرم اهلهم من حقهم في دفن
ابنائهم بكرامه
[موسيقى]
وتخلل الاعتصامات وقوع صدامات عند حاجز
قلنديا العسكري شمال مدينه رام الله واكد
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني تسجيل
اصابه بالقدم دون تحديد طبيعتها